[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 78 nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv78
nous sommes le lundi 16 octobre voici
les titres ellisabeth born et Gabriel
Atal au collège du bois d'Old à
conflance saint-onorine la première
ministre et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale ont assisté aujourd'hui à la M
de silence en hommage à Dominique
Bernard le professeur de français tué
dans une attaque terroriste vendredi à
haras c'est au collège du boisolne
d'ailleurs qu'enseignit Samuel pati dont
nous commémorons ce lundi les 3 ans de
son assassinat rassemblement est prévu
ce soir dans la ville nous serons sur
place une minute de silence dans toutes
les écoles de France aujourd'hui mais
aussi dans beaucoup de communes
ivelinoises qui ont eu une pensée pour
Dominique Bernard élu et habitants se
sont rassemblés à la mi-journée nous
étions à plaisir et Manil à le sport est
du football le 5e tour de la Coupe de
France pas d'exploit réalisé par les
joueurs de nfle Pontchartrain face au
Redstar quatre divisions séparé les deux
équipe les ivelinois ont été battus sur
leur pelouse 5-1 par le club de National
devant un public un public venu en
nombre et puis l'invité du 78 en 2uxè
partie d'émission on y parle des
rendez-vous de la retraite qui se
tiennent jusqu'à samedi près de 10000
entretiens sont proposés au franilien
par laagic arco et l'assurance retraite
l'objectif c'est d'informer et d'aider
les actifs à préparer l'aprèscarrière
professionnelle et ce sera donc avec
vous Olivier stevgen bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes directeur retraite à laagic
arco et vous êtes donc avec nous en
plateau on parlera de ce sujet un peu
plus tard dans cette émission tout à
l'heure on parlera de des des
rendez-vous de la retraite dans en
quelques minutes en face de vous il y a
également Michel midoro bonsoir de la
rédaction TV 78 alors avec vous aussi
toute l'actualité sportive des Evelin ce
sera tout à l'heure qu'est-ce qu'il est
au menu ce soir on parlera de la Coupe
de France hein comme vous l'avez dit euh
le Red St a battu nafle mais il reste
des clubs Évinois encore en course pour
ce 6e tour de la Coupe de France il y
aura notamment Versailles Chatou et ou
qui se sont qualifiés pour ce 6e tour on
parlera également de rugby et de la
fédérale 2 avec les victoires de
Versailles et de plaisir restez avec
nous ce sera tout à l'heure dans le
78 une minute de silence dans tous les
établissements scolaires de France c'est
l'hommage qui a été rendu aujourd'hui à
14h à Dominique Bernard le professeur de
français a été poignardé à mort vendredi
lors d'une attaque terroriste survenue
dans un collège lycée d'aras dans le pas
decalais la première ministre ellisabeth
borne et le ministre de l'éducation
nationale Gabriel Atal ont choisi le
collège du bois d'Olne à Conflant
saint-onorine pour assister à cet
hommage c'est là qu'enseignait Samuel
paatti autre victime du terrorisme
islamiste le professeur
d'histoire-géographie avait été tué à
proximité de l'établissement il y a 3
ans jour pour jour le 16 octobre 2020
ellisabeth borne et Gabriel Atal sont
arrivés peu avant 14h et sont restés sur
place une trentaine de minutes ils ont
pu échanger à huclos avec des collégiens
et des professeurs sur place notamment
et Natalia pousirev député de la 6e
circonscription des Evelin qui était au
micro de Gabrielle Gontier et Mathilde
Francou les échanges avec les élèves qui
étaient très attentif très
ouvert et qui avait le sentiment que
effectivement c'est un moment important
grave on voit bien qu'il y a des équipes
enseignantes qui sont solides qui sont
engagé pour faire en sorte qu'on
n'oublie pas mais qu'en même temps cette
génération puisse se projeter se sentir
en sécurité et se projeter dans dans
dans l'avenir et qu'ils aient confiance
en en eux qu'ils aient confiance en la
République et toujours à Conflant
saintonorie nous retrouvons sur place
Gabriel Gontier bonsoir
Gabriel bonsoir boir Grégory journée
particulière ce lundi en plus de
l'hommage à Dominique Bernard c'est
aussi le 16 octobre aujourd'hui le 16
octobre les 3 ans de l'assassinat de
Samuel paatti et un hommage a lieu ce
soir justement à conflan saint-onorine
ça démarre à 18h30
oui vous l'avez dit ans après le
souvenir est toujours présent ici à
conflan saint-honorine alors nous sommes
sur la place de la Liberté c'est ici
qu'aura lieu dans quelques minutes un
hommage en la mémoire de Sam Samuel
paatti c'est d'ailleurs sur cette place
vous le voyez derrière moi qu'une
sculpture en forme de livre avait été
érigée une œuvre contre l'oubli et pour
réaffirmer la liberté d'expression
l'enseignant avait été tué puis décapité
le 16 octobre 2020 quelques semaines
après avoir montréicature de mahomé à
ses élèves ce soir nul doute que
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard le
professeur d'aras tué vendredi dernier
par un ancien élève fichs est également
dans toutes les têtes alors là nous
sommes sur la place de la Liberté de
nombreuses personnes commencent à
arriver vous l'avez dit le début de
l'hommage commence à 18h30 Gabriel
grontier depuis Conflant saint-honorie
avec mathil de Francou pour les moyens
techniques nous reviendrons sur ce
rassemblement dans notre édition de
demain 3 ans donc jour pour jour après
l'assassinat de Samuel paatti ce drame
est encore dans toutes les têtes et sur
le terrain judiciaire rappelons que
l'affaire est toujours en cours en
septembre la cour d'appel de Paris a
confirmé le jugement prochain de 14
personnes pour le meurtre de Samuel pati
suite à l'assassinat du professeur
Dominique Bernard àas ce vendredi un
appel au rassemblement était organisé
devant de nombreuses mairies des
ivelines aujourd'hui à manilamot et
plaisir plus d'une cinquantaine
d'habitants se sont mobilisés face à la
barbarie le reportage de Clara de Frutos
et Julien Laura un hommage pour ne pas
oublier ce vendredi 13 octobre Dominique
Bernard professeur de lettres était
assassiné par un terroriste islamiste au
sein de son lycée à AR ce lundi 16
octobre de nombreux recueillements ét
organisés par les communes ivelinoises
pour saluer sa
mémoire à Manil et à Mo ils étaient une
cinquantaine d'habitants au pied de
l'hôtel de ville un besoin de se
retrouver ensemble contre la barbarie en
cette journée qui commémorait les 3 ans
de l'assassinat du professeur Samuel
paatti à Conflant saint-onorine je suis
parent d'élèv j'ai deux enfants dont une
jeune fille de 14 ans qui est scolarisé
au collège amaniie et parler de ça avec
nos enfants bah c'est super important
hein c'est la transmission bon elle se
pose quand même pas mal de questions
aussi hein bon est-ce que je suis en
sécurité l'école l'éducation nationale
dans notre pays Ben est un socle qui
permet de transmettre un certain nombre
de valeurs et notamment toutes les
valeurs qui font notre vivre ensemble
les questions de liberté d'égalité la
fraternité et puis la laïcité à plaisir
les habitants se sont rassemblés au côté
de la Mer de la ville pour combattre la
peur et soutenir le corps enseignant on
a besoin de sentir qu'on est tous
ensemble le rassemblement fait aussi et
ben la sérénité apporte aussi cette
force parce que le rassemblement il peut
être violent il peut être combatif mais
nous on est dans le combat de la paix je
me sens concerné parce que déjà je suis
maman et je suis grand-mère et mon
gendre est prof aussi donc je j'ai peur
j'ai peur pour ma famille d'être tous
rassemblés ça nous fait du bien on a
besoin de se rassembler pour vivre
ensemble ces moments-l des
rassemblements se sont tenus dans la
plupart des communes de saint-quanttin
en iveline le président de
l'agglomération Jean-Michel Fourgous a
lui choisi de suivre la minute de
silence dans une classe de l'école de la
Nouvelle Amsterdam à
hlencour un rassemblement est d'ailleurs
prévu à éloncour il était même prévu à
18h et il est toujours en cours d'autres
C commune comme trappe coignère ont
choisi la journée de demain mardi pour
rendre hommage au professeur Dominique
Bernard le point présent sur les autres
actualités du jour dans les
ivelines et c'est avec vous Michael el
midoro dans le reste de l'actualité les
conséquences bien sûr de cette attaque
terroriste d'aras la France est
actuellement placée en alerte urgence
attentat et ce matin la Présidente de la
Région Île-de-France Valérie PCR annoncé
un renforcement de la sécurité dans les
lycée de la région les brigades
régionales de sécurité vont être doublé
pour passer de 50 à 100 agents sur le
terrain en attendant ses recrutements
Valérie pcrè a aussi annoncé que la
région allait faire appel à la sécurité
privée et à des brigades cinophiles pour
sécuriser les abords des lycées qui en
feront la demande elle plaide également
pour un renforcement des clôtures des
portiques d'accès et des sacs dans les
établissements l'Île-de-France a
constaté une hausse de 12 % des faits de
violence dans les lycées du territoire
dans l'actualité également l'homme
ficher S qui a été arrêté vendredi aux
abords justement d'un lycée de Limet et
jugé aujourd'hui l'homme de 24 ans a été
arrêté avec un Coutau vendredi dernier
les policiers l'avaient repéré aux
abords du lycée con d'orsé il a été jugé
aujourd'hui en comparition immédiate au
tribunal de Versailles pour port d'armes
ce dernier est connu des services de
police pour au moins cinq faits
similaires aucun trouble psychiatrique
n'a été révélé lors de son expertise
selon mon confrère de BFM TV des photos
de décapitation ont été retrouvé dans
son téléphone portable et Onra bien sûré
dès qu'on aura le verdict de ce jugement
en comparution immédiate est-ce que le
château de versaill sera bien ouvert
demain Michel oui sauf changement de
dernière minute ce sera bien le cas
samedi aux alentours de 16h le City
Vinois avait dû être évacué et fermé
après une alerte à la bombe 10000
personnes se trouvaient sur place à ce
moment-là c'est un anonyme qui a lancé
l'alerte sur le site
mon.commissariat.fr la menace s'est
avérée être un canular de très mauvais
goût aujourd'hui tout est rentré dans
l'ordre rassurez-vous le château de de
Versailles a rouvert ses portes dès hier
dimanche et puis dans ce contexte tendu
un rassemblement pour la paix a eu lieu
hier à poissie les représentants des
communautés juives musulmanes et
chrétiennes de la ville étaient présents
autour d'une cinquantaine de pisiaqués
objectif montré l'unité entre les
religions face à la montée des tensions
en France suite au conflit
israëlo-palestinien on écoute la mère de
poissis Sandrine Berna Dos Santos au
micro de Michel mon micro c'est même pas
la mairie qui a demandé au cultes de se
réunir c'est les cultes qui spontanément
ont décidé de de de se réunir pour
montrer que qu'il y a des endroits où on
peut bien vivre ensemble et que voilà
c'est pas toujours compliqué quand on
est quand on appartient à des cultes
différents ben de pouvoir
cohabiter merci Michell et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi près de chez
vous vous êtes témoins d'une actualité
qui vous fait réagir dans les ivelines
n'hésitez pas à la partager sur les
réseaux sociaux en utilisant le hashtag
7we
[Musique]
news
allez un peu plus de légèreté à présent
dans le 78 avec la partie sport du
football pour débuter mais bon c'est pas
forcément de de très bonnes nouvelles
alors on jouit ce weekend le 5e tour de
la Coupe de France l'équipe de nfle au
Pontchartrain a été sortie ce dimanche
par le Red Star après sa défaite 5 à1 à
domicile le résumé du match c'était
l'ambiance des grands jours à nfle le
château l'équipe locale qui évolue en
régional 2 recevait le Red Star leader
de national à l'occasion du 5e tour de
la Coupe de France dans les 10 premiers
minute les deux équipes se rendent coup
pour coup mais sur cette action les
quatre divisions d'écart se font sentir
le Red Star marque les ver réussiront
ensuite à inscrire deux autres buts
avant la pause 3-0 on sait que sur les
matchs de coupe le danger c'est si le
match dure un petit peu on peut on peut
se mettre en difficulté on a vu que
c'était une équipe aussi qui a pu
parfois nous mettre en difficulté donc
faut qu'on soit absolument très
concentré sur ces éléments là et ça
passe par un très très bon début de
match et ce qu'on a fait c'était c'était
important pour nous au début on s'en
sortait quand même aime bien au début on
les a on on leur a fait un bon pressing
qu'on avait travail entraînement comme
j'ai dit mais ensuite comme je dit c'est
tactiquement tactiquement ilétait un
petit peu audessus pourut dire la vérité
et voilà au retour des vestiaires NF le
pont charartin met plus d'impact et se
met à réver avec ce but inscrit à la 55e
minute par sikouara mais le Red Star
accélère et inscrit un nouveau but 4
minutes plus tard puis un autre à la 72e
minute score final 5 à1 on savait he ils
étaient fort et bon bah ça fait du bien
aussi de jouer contre eux c'est une
bonne équipe
le meilleur pour eux et franchement
c'est bien aussi dans l'expérience de
pouvoir jouer contre une équipe comme ça
c'est une belle équipe sincèrement c'est
ce que je disais je pense qu'il y a des
joueurs qui peuvent jouer audessus je
pense au numéro 10 au numéro 9 on a vu
des joueurs qui ont qui ont défendu leur
maillot et ça c'est une c'est une grande
fierté pour eux ils se sont bien
comportés je pense qu'on a vu un bon
match de football cet après-midi nont
Chartrin devra se replonger rapidement
dans le quotidien du championnat de
régional 2 les ivinois joueront ce
dimanche 22 Octobre à domicile contre
Paris
15 bravo tout de même à nofle
Pontchartrin d'avoir atteint ce 5e tour
de la Coupe de France ils ont marqué un
but quand même contre ils ont marqué un
but contre le Red Star d'abibeay alors
toujours au menu de la Coupe de France
trois autres équipes ivelinoises vont
continuer l'aventure oui il s'agit de
Versailles Chatou et ouille les
Versaillais se sont imposé 3-0 sur le
terrain de saintclou de son côté ouassé
a gagné à domicile ce dimanche contre
Linas montlerry enfin Chatou s'est
imposé 4 à 2 au tir au but face à
noiséen c'est en revanche terminé pour
vilain Orgeval qui a perdu contre
hisienne et ou Yasso sorti au tir au but
les rencontres du 6e tour auront lieu
les samedi 28 octobre et le dimanche 29
octobre 29 octobre partout en France
comme d'habitude on espère qu'un petit
poussé evelinois ira loin dans cette
compétition croise les do on croise les
doigts dans les résultats du weekend
également Duan ball dans le championnat
de National 3 l'équipe du chînet Eveline
handbal s'est imposé assez facilement
sur le terrain de calis le score est
sans appel 31 à 25 au classement à cette
victoire permet aux ivinois de s'emparer
de la seconde place de la poule avec 14
points au compteur et a un bilan de 4
victoires et un nul on joue également en
fédéral 2 c'est du rugby on jouit la 4e
journée du championnat samedi versaill
s'est imposé dans la douleur contre
jeuneevilliers sur le score de 21 à 15
de son côté plaisir gagne 32 à 19 contre
plousané dimanche et enfin le MLSGP
s'incline assez lourdement 41 à 20
contre Anthony au classement plaisir est
plus que jamais leader avec 6 points
d'avance sur Anthony les Versaillais
sont qu à eu 5e et enfin le MLSGP est
11e sur 12 bon on va parler de rugby et
de Coupe du monde alors on va pas parler
du 15 de France peut-être encore qu'il y
a peut-être des des cicatrices qui ne se
referment pas là-dessus mais on va
parler du du quart de finale alors on va
pas parler du quart de finale contre
l'Afrique du Sud justement on va parler
d'une autre équipe qui elle est toujours
en LCE et qui va en plus s'entraîner
dans les evelines c'est ça exactement
les all black vont s'installer cette
semaine sur la commune de croissie
sursène on sait jamais si vous voulez
aller les voir Grégory ils vont préparer
leur demi-finale de Coupe du monde
contre l'Argentine sur le terrain
municipal de la ville un premier
entraînement est déjà programmé ce lundi
soir dans la commune la ville de Croatie
sur scène a déjà accueilli deux équipes
de ce Mondial les Tonga et l'Afrique du
Sud juste avant le match contre l'équipe
de France donc la Nouvelle-Zélande qui
est peut-être l'un des gros favoris de
de cette Coupe du monde avec l'Afrique
du Sud he qui a éliminé cette équipe de
France on en parle plus on va on va
passer un sujet différent dans dans ce
78 et vous nous parlez de golf
maintenant alors le français Mathieu
Pavon vient de remporter sa toute
première victoire en carrière sur le DP
World Tour en s'imposant sur l'Open
d'Espagne alors vous allez me dire
greégory quel est le rapport avec les
ivlines il y en a un car cette victoire
permet à Mathieu Pavon de se replacer
pour être aux Jeux olympiques de 2024 il
pourrait représenter la France sur les
Green du Golf National de 50 ans lesvin
l'année prochaine il est en concurrence
avec Victor prez ou encore le
versaillais Antoine Rosen pour ravir
l'une des deux places chez les hommes
c'est le classement mondial au 17 juin
2024 qui décidera des joueurs retenus
pour représenter leur pays au j de Paris
2024 dans l'actualité aussi du paragolf
c'était la semaine dernière le président
du département des ivelines Pierre
Bédier est venu au golf de maison lafide
pour rencontrer une section andisport
qui s'est créé il y a 2 ans sur la
structure le site était pionnier sur
cette thématique en Île-de-France le
département les aide financièrement avec
des subventions on écoute les réactions
au micro de
tv78 ils ont près de 300 participants et
ils me disent la la joie de ces golfeurs
de pouvoir retrouver enfin de ces
golfeurs de ces paragolfeurs de pouvoir
retrouver une sociabilité à travers
cette cette pratique de l'exercice et du
sport ah ben je crois que c'est une
belle opération quand on intervient
auprès de personnes en situation de
handicap un événement qui s'est déroulé
ce weekend à présent la 2e édition de
l'aquathlon des bertisette organisé par
l'Union Sportive de virof s'est déroulé
ce dimanche 15 octobre dans la ville le
concept les participants ont enchaîné
une épreuve de natation dans la piscine
de la commune et une course à pied dans
la forêt au total 210 sportifs ont
participé à l'épreuve dans l'épreuve ren
le 400 m de natation et le 3 km de
course Théo bourdri et Sophie martinau
du club de viroflet ont terminé un
premier et on termine avec du cyclisme
c'était ce samedi dans les ivelines une
balade de 35 km entre Saint-Germain de
la grange et 50 an livin était organisé
à l'occasion de l'événement le vélo dans
tous ses états cette occasion 35
cyclistes ont pu découvrir à vélo les
différents sites olympiques ctinois qui
vont accueillir les épreuves de cyclisme
en 2024 comme la colline de lencour le
vélodrome national le Stadium de BMX on
écoute l'organisateur micro de Régine
ralèche on est dans une année olympique
on a la chance dans le département des
evvelines à avoir trois magnifiques
sites entre le BMX le VTT et la piste
donc c'était un moyen de faire
découvrir un certain nombre de personnes
ces sites olympiques merci Michel pour
toutes ces informations sportives on se
revoit la semaine prochaine je serai là
comme d'habitude dans le 78 le lundi
dans un instant l'invité du 78 mais
juste avant on va regarder les
prévisions météo de
demain Siel VO aller demain matin dans
les Yvelines avec un thermomètre au-delà
qui sera pardon en dessous des 10°gr le
matin il fera 7°gr sur tout le
territoire ivelinois dans l'après-midi
mêmes condition météo avec cette fois-ci
un thermomètre qui grimpe avec 15°gr
dans les secteurs de Mantel jolie et
Rambouillet et 16°gr àou dans
eteverersaill demain mardi 17 octobre
nous fêterons les beauoins tout de suite
l'invité du 78
[Musique]
et on parle de ce rendez-vous qui a lieu
jusqu'au 21 octobre son nom justement
les rendez-vous de la retraite près de
9600 entretiens vont avoir lieu en
Île-de-France pour anticiper bien
préparer sa future retraite un
événnement organisé par la la jirk arco
et l'assurance retraite et on en parle
justement avec vous Olivier Stev je
disais tout à l'heure vous êtes
directeur retraite à laagirk Arco alors
j'ai du mal à prononcer cet acronim
est-ce qu'on peut le détailler déjà
qu'est-ce que cette agirk Arco alors
l'agirk Arco c'est le régime de de
retraite complémentaire des des salariés
du privé donc c'est à la fois le régime
des cadres et des non cadres et il vient
en complément du régime de base le
régime général l'Assurance Retraite donc
on a un système à deux étages en France
un système de retraite de base et un
système de retraite complémentaire et
donc c'est l'occasion effectivement de à
partir depuis ce matin jusqu'à samedi
effectivement du du 16 au 21 de de mener
cette deuxème opération puisque nous
menons deux opérations dans l'année des
rendez-vous de la retraite de semaines
de rendez-vous de la retraite faites
conjointement alors initié il y a
presque une dizaine d'années par l'ager
Carco et maintenant depuis plus de 3 ans
en association en partenariat complet
avec l'Assurance Retraite donc ça permet
effectivement de pouvoir donner une
information complète à toutes les
Françaises et les Français qui
s'intéressent à la retraite on le voit
bien depuis quelques moi de manière
générale mais surtout à leur retraite en
particulier c'est un sujet qui est bien
marqué qui a bien marqué l'actualité ces
derniers temps juste préciser que pour
ces rendez-vous de la retraite plusieurs
lieux d'accueil sont dans les Yvelines
on peut citer les agences de guancour
mont-elajolie ou encore Montini le
bretonux vous l'avez dit l'idée c'est de
bien préparer sa retraite c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut anticiper à l'avance
c'est c'est difficile de préparer sa
retraite de bien préparer saors c'est
pas difficile de préparer sa retraite
quand on s'y prend à temps et quand on
s'y prend à l'avance vous avez raison de
le souligner la retraite c'est
quelqueose chose qu'il faut préparer le
plus tôt possible alors on n'est pas
obligé de le démarrer à 25 ans quand on
rentre dans la vie active encore que
c'est important de s'informer ce qui est
important c'est au moins en 2ième partie
de carrière de pouvoir faire le point
justement sur sa carrière sur les droits
acquis c'està-dire les trimestres au
régime général ou les points dans le
régime complémentaire et puis d'avoir à
partir de 40 45 ans une première
estimation de ce que pourrait être l'âge
de départ et surtout une estimation
financière du montant futur de la
retraite parce que ce sont les deux
questions que nous pose le le public en
en règle générale quand vais-je pouvoir
par partir et combien vais-je pouvoir
toucher donc je prends un exemple
concret Michel et moi nous sommes
trentenir plutôt à partir de 40 ans il
faudrait commcer déjà intéressez-vous à
ce qui é indiqué sur mentionn sur votre
fiche de paye puisque vous avez
notamment les points àer Carco euh et
puis surtout euh si vous venez pas
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la Semaine
des rendez-vous de la retraite qui
concerne plutôt des des actifs entre
guillemets en fin de carrière ou des
vraiment des proches proches de départ à
la retraite nous avons aussi tout un tas
de services qui sont aujourd'hui ouverts
au grand public donc nous avons un site
internet par exemple aujourd'hui pour la
semaine des rendez-vous de la retraite
un site très simple rendez-vous de la
retraite rdv- retraite qui va peut-être
s'afficher dans quelques instants parce
que on peut on peut le proposer à noter
spectateur il va sans doute s'afficher r
tir retraite vous avez déjà plein
d'informations et puis après on a aussi
développé d'autres outils notamment un
simulateur Marel peut-être qu'on pourra
vous pourrez aussi donner les références
qui permettent justement de faire une
simulation d'avoir une estimation de son
montant futur de retraite et puis enfin
euh deux choses importantes je pense se
créer son espace personnal hraite
Soco et puis un dernier outil qui une
application sur smartphone mon
contre-retraite qui est très bien faite
qui est très simple d'utilisation qui
permet à chacun individuellement d'avoir
le point sur sa situation vos droits à
quiis aujourd'hui et pouvoir se projeter
parce que l'important c'est
effectivement de pouvoir se projeter
d'anticiper cette cette période qui est
un changement qui est une rupture quand
même importante on passe de la vie
active professionnelle à une une
situation de retraite de retraité pardon
et il faut pouvoir l'anticiper y compris
sur le plan financier je voyais réagir
Michel vous aviez peut-être une question
non non c'était pour voilà c'est
exactement ce que vous disiez je voulais
savoir moi l'âge exactement à laquelle
il fallait il fallait y aller tout
simplement pourp ou commencer à prendre
des renseignements prendre les
renseignnement je pense qu'à partir de
30 ans 35 ans c'est important déjà de
comprendre comment marche le système de
retraite en France bien sûr à 30 ans 35
ans il est encore tôt effectivement
puceque vous savez comme moi que l'âge
va progressivement passer de 62 à 64 ans
donc c'est plutôt dans la deuxème partie
de carrière qu'il faut s intéresser mais
il faut s'y intéresser pour
effectivement connaître à peu près quel
âge on pourra partir mais aussi je
parlais tout à l'heure de revenus de
remplacement parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre qu'effectivement quand on
passe à la retraite il y a une perte de
revenu et ça ça s'anticipe par
différentes choses ça peut s'anticiper
parce que la retraite touche plein de
sujets ça peut toucher effectivement le
le sujet de l'acquisition d'un d'un bien
effectivement il faut peut-être
l'anticiper parce qu'il faut anticiper
cette période qui est une période
nouvelle donc c'est aussi pour ça que
nous faisons cette opération deux fois
par an de semaines complètes plus de
50000 rendez-vous vous avez vous l'avez
dit près de 10000 en île defance
500 le territoire français c'est près de
500s d'accueil qui vont recevoir
effectivement 50000 personnes et
j'insiste en entretien individualisé
c'est chaque Français chaque française
est reçu personnellement avec un
conseiller qui fera le point sur sa
carrière lui donnera de la visibilité
sur ses droits et pourra répondre à ces
deux questions dont je parlais tout à
l'heure à partir de quand vais-je
pouvoir partir surtout dans le contexte
actuel de de réforme qui se met en place
justement est-ce qu'on peut rappeler les
dernières évolutions récentes en alors
la dernière évolution c'est celle qui du
projet de loi qui a été voté au mois
d'avril avec de deux alors c'est d'abord
il faut bien avoir en tête que la
réforme des retraites touche le régime
général en touchant le régime général
elle a bien sûr un impact sur le régime
complémentaire agir Carco deux
dispositions effectivement assez simples
je pense que que tout le monde
a bien a bien a bien compris euh donc un
passage progressif de 62 à 64 ans c'est
l'âge de départ légal en France sauf
conditions particulières carrière longue
mais restons dans le cas général
aujourd'hui on part on ne peut pas à
partir avant 62 ans d'ici quelques
années c'est un trimestre par an qui va
être gagné enfin gagné ça dépend comment
on se place mais qui va être nécessaire
on pourra partir on ne pourra partir
qu'à partir de 64 ans et puis au-delà de
l'âge il y a aussi une durée d'assurance
de cotisation qui qui elle aussi
s'accélère un tout petit peu puisque
aujourd'hui il faut 168 trimestres pour
avoir ce qu'on appelle le to plein je
vais pas être trop technique mais pour
toucher la totalité de sa carrière euh
d'ici moins de 10 ans il faudra minimum
172 trimestres voilà et donc donc dans
le régime ager Carco on a aussi pris les
les les mesures puisque les parten
puisque le régime agercco est un régime
qui est géré par les partenaires sociaux
il viennent les partenaires sociaux
représentants des employeurs et des
salariés viennent de signer un accord la
semaine dernière qui prend en compte
effectivement l'impact de de ces
modifications de de Born d'âge toute
dernière chose on l'a dit ça se déroule
donc jusqu'à samedi est-ce qu'on peut
encore prendre rendez-vous est-ce que
c'est possible alors ça a démarré ce
matin ça se déroule jusqu'à samedi dans
les points d'accueil que vous avez
évoqué les rendez-vous ont été pris
parfois un petit peu à l'avance mais ce
matin encore dans l'agence de Guillan
courour il y avait quelques rendez-vous
donc n'hésitez pas à téléphoner je vous
donne le numéro de téléphone le
0970 660 660 allez sur le site
rdv-retraite vous aurez toutes les infos
dans la dans dans le courant de la
semaine il y a même trois webinaires
trois webinaires pardon sur des
thématiques particulières pour évoquer
un certain nombre de sujets de la
retraite et puis les sites internet
l'application mon compte retraite qui
est vraiment une application je vous
encourage messieurs vous êtes un peu
plus jeune que moi à créer votre compte
et aller voir sur mon compte retraite
vous verrez que c'est assez bluffant
vous y trouverez des informations vous
avez peut-être même oublié et vous
pourrez commencer à vous projeter dans
ce qui la retraite future on a pris
bonne note qu'il faut déjà commencer
Michel à s'informer les rendez-vous de
la retraite on le rappelle c'est donc
jusqu'à samedi ce 21 octobre merci
Olivier stepgen d'être venu en parler
sur ce plateau voilà c'est la fin du 78
merci de votre fidélité tout de suite à
la découverte des evvelines belle soirée
sur
tv78
[Musique]